as I've already underscored in my speech
on Europe in Prague by the end of August
um the sixth Balkan states are part of
the European Union they belong into the
European Union they're part of the
European family and part of Europe and
this is why I have always come out very
strongly in favor of enlarging the
European Union to include the states of
the western Balkan and the so-called
Berlin process is very important for the
success of EU enlargement I'm delighted
therefore to be able to welcome today
and I was able to welcome today rather
the representatives of the participating
States and institutions to the Berlin
process and I was gratified to see that
all of the minister presence of this
sales of Western Balkans came to Berlin
um accepted our invitation this Berlin
process takes place ever since 2014 now
for the third time under the German
Championship so to speak and we have
hosted it and I'm also very glad that I
was able to have here prime minister
adirama of Albania he will be hosting
the next meeting and the president of
the European commission Ozil underline
is also present here as you can see
presenting the success and the results
of this Summit and the development of
the western Balkans and its integration
into the EU is Central to me the U
accession is in our interests and that
is all the more important against the
background of the brutal war of
aggression of Russia against Ukraine
reforms are necessary with us in the EU
itself but also in the region in
particular as regards rule of law and
environmental standards and physicists
it is necessary to bring Regional
cooperation forward and to settle
long-smokering conflicts among these six
countries and an improved Regional
cooperation of the countries of the
western Balkans is key to speeding up
the EU Repro ever since 2000 14 the
Berlin process gives a very important
contribution to this effect and it has
brought together the people it has also
increased links in the region at all
levels New Roads new interconnectors
um in doing so it has strengthened the
economy has also given a concrete
contribution towards improving good
neighborly relations and Reconciliation
in the region very concretely and what
we are talking today is the creation of
a common regional market that is
compatible with EU rules it's also
including all of the men the countries
of the region and I congratulate these
countries of the western Balkan that
today under the auspices of the federal
government and the regional Corporation
Council free Mobility agreements could
be signed and that is a great success
for the citizens of the region and it
shows that the six Western Balkan states
are serious in trying to get closer to
Regional cooperation as we regards the
European Union for in this European
project it has always been about going
forward together these three agreements
now that will make it possible for the
citizens of the region to travel to
cross borders just by using their IDs
and also there is mutual recognition
enshrined in one agreement of higher
education qualifications and
professional qualifications this will in
very concrete terms improve the life of
the individuals in the region and get
the region closer together and on energy
an important agreement an important
declaration has also been signed the
Western Balkan countries and agree in
this declaration to work together more
closely for more energy and security and
also on climate protection measures in
order to achieve the 2030 goal we the
other participants of the Berlin process
are going to support the Western ball
concerts in the medium and short term
and long term obviously in order to
whether this energy crisis and to focus
on inner numerals Germany contributes to
this through the work of its promotional
Bank FW in the short terms for granting
loans of up to 500 million and in order
to weather this acute crisis and at the
medium term
by 2030 so supporting energy transition
for the Western Balkans to the tune of 1
billion euros and all of these issues we
need to work together more closely this
Summit has shown that there is a
willingness to cooperate until Europe
Germany is going to support this process
in the future and will also obviously be
willing to host this process again in
the future the EU also supports this
process and here in particular the
European commission supports this and we
would like to thank the commission for
doing this and I would like to now hand
the floor and give the floor Rover to
the commission president Ozil on the
line before the next host of the Berlin
process Summit will take the floor
because then the floor is yours
Benya in the driving seat for next year
I know that the Berlin process continues
to be in very good hands so our aim is
very clear it's the aim to bring our
Western Balkan Partners as close as
possible as fast as possible and here we
have two tracks one track of work is of
course the accession process
there we have made good progress the
commission has put enlargement back on
the table from the very first day of my
mandate
we have been securing agreement on a new
enlargement methodology
that opened up ways not only to de-block
decisions that was very important
but it also brought back credibility to
the whole process
then we have put on the table a
substantive economic and investment plan
it brings 30 billion euros of investment
to the region which is overall
approximately one-third of the GDP of
the whole region
in addition last year we had the first
intergovernmental conference we had
intergovernment conference with
Montenegro we opened one cluster with
Serbia and this year we were very happy
that we finally managed to have the
first intergovernmental conference with
Albania and North Macedonia started the
screening process and we made the
proposal to council to give Bosnian at
Herzegovina candidate status
I must say this progress which is good
progress the adirama was possible
because of the progress made in the
western Balkan countries themselves so
it's your success
indeed a second track of action is the
Berlin process
and here the goal is to deepen our
economic integration
and yes we are facing many full
challenges
most and foremost Russia's invasion of
Ukraine that marks a geopolitical shift
on our continent
but the longer the Russian war lasts the
more determined we are to stand together
and to withstand
we know that our investments in the
western Balkans are not only important
for a conducive business environment
this is also the case but that these
Investments are investments for peace
stability and prosperity of Europe as a
whole
against this backdrop indeed we
discussed in depth the knock-on effects
of the Russian war on energy
and therefore today's Declaration on
energy security and the green agenda for
the Western Balkans Mark a very
important step
as the chancellor already said we are
united knighted in the goal of climate
neutrality by 2050 and our climate
targets by 2013.
now if we look at the immediate crisis
it's important that we synchronize our
steps we are in an energy community
therefore in the short term this means
for all of us
diversification of energy sources
the reduction of our dependency on
Russian fossil fuels and to keep Energy
prices in check with joint action
but we are also aware of the fact that
unprecedented crises
demand or need unprecedented steps and
action
and therefore I am pleased to announce
that the commission will put forward a
substantial energy support package
for the Western Balkans it's 1 billion
euros in Grants and it has two different
parts
the first part is 500 million euros in
Grants as a very immediate financial
support for the six Western Balkan
countries
to put them in a position for the very
short term to support vulnerable
households and vulnerable businesses
this budget support will be adopted in
December and available in January in
other words very short term
the second part the other 500 million
euros in Grants will be dedicated to
investments in energy infrastructure
so these are Mainly Investments in gas
and electricity interconnectors to
really have a common grid and
interconnection in the region with the
European Union
very important is the emphasis on
investments on renewable energy because
this gives us independence it's clean
energy and it creates good jobs at home
and of course Energy Efficiency measures
in addition we will strengthen the
security of Supply by improving and
facilitating the access in each other's
energy pipelines and storages this is
for the emergency in case that somebody
is in trouble there is solidarity from
all of us
and the European Union and the Western
Balkans will harmonize
the crisis and emergency plans and
measures in a spirit of solidarity and
increased Mutual resilience
finally
we are also inviting our partners from
the Western Balkans to join us in our
European attempt to have a joint
procurement platform so really to
develop these strong Market power we
have if we stick together
and this brings me to the second point
the regional integration
that's the development of the common
regional market
it is for us a very important stepping
stone towards the EU single Market
and indeed in this regard I welcome
today's signature of the three very
important agreements
the freedom of movement is key to both
it's key to the development of the
common regional market of course
but it's also key to the integration of
the western Balkan in the European
single Market it's about the people
be it students be it professionals they
will bring the region forward and
therefore the agreement is so important
for 18 million people to move freely
within the region
professionals can tap their full
potential regardless of where they work
and the professional qualifications be
it of skilled workers students
researchers medical doctors dentists or
Architects they will all be recognized
recognized throughout the Western
Balkans
very important is also that the national
ID cards will be accepted at every
border
so these measures will not only boost
intra-regional travel in the western
Balkans but it will also strengthen
personal and cultural bonds between the
people of the region
and in the very end it's always the same
good old story that has always been at
the heart of the European project it's
enhanced cooperation and harmonization
that bring peace and prosperity to all
so we should use every opportunity to
get closer with our Best Western Balkan
friends and thank you once more for a
very good Berlin process
thank you very much and I must say that
everyone from the region was very
pleased to be here today in Berlin
eight years after
the Berlin process
was launched in this very same building
and
I must also say that
Angela Merkel was proven right because
if today we have a United region in a
very complicated moments of history for
all Europe
and for the whole euro-atlantic
community
the public secret is the Berlin process
when we gathered here for first time
we hadn't
meet each other for
centuries and nowadays this is very very
much what we all
like to do and I would like to really
thank wholeheartedly Chancellor Schultz
for
his engagements
for the great hospitality
for the outstanding German bread
and of course
last but not least for
trusting Albania and myself
to host the next Berlin process Summit
in our wonderful country and I very much
hope that
what was discussed today and taken
carefully uh in the notes of the
chancellory
will
see a progress in the next Summit in
Tirana
starting from the energy crisis where
we feel that we are not left aside we
are not alone because
just a few days ago
the president of the European commission
Ursula
made a tour in the Balkans and she
didn't just bring
nice words of solidarity but also
uh very important
financial support
important to start with not to end with
of course and in the same time we are
looking forward to see progress in the
interconnectivity
as the chancellor pointed out very very
clearly it's not about connecting
our own infrastructure highways
in our countries but it's about
connecting the region and Europe
with the region Vice and vice versa
we
hope to see progress
in the digital sphere because these were
the three main pillars of the bearing
process since day one energy
interconductivity and digital but today
we are also facing the challenge of
cyber security and it was discussed
and of course we want to see things move
in the right direction for our young
people we have raised again the issue of
how we can faster integrate with the
European uh higher education system our
universities and uh also of uh of of of
on how we can have more uh presence from
Germany and other
EU
well-developed countries through their
private sector and not just Public
Funding
to end with my
I hope short
introduction I want to say that it's
very important what we signed today
I cannot prevent myself to underline the
disagreements
were three agreements that we were
looking forward since two or three years
they were blocked the chancellory the
chancellor his team
really worked very hard together with
our people to convince everyone to sign
and it's a great great news that uh we
had today three important signatures
that we already
had in the open Balkan framework so it's
very important that now everyone is
included in this in this framework of
um the three agreements of course uh
sounds a bit a bit uh weird or or a bit
alienating for the
people of kosova that while they
made another step through the government
to sign this uh free movement with ID
cards can't yet move freely
as everyone else in the region when it
comes to
the European Union and I very much hope
that this will be solved sooner more
than later so looking forward to host
everyone next year in Tirana and being
very very happy that we will
holds the chancellor and others next
month in Tirana again
we were
laughing a bit because everyone was
talking about
becoming a hub of energy
but apparently piranha is becoming a hub
of summits
foreign
I prefer to speak in my language there's
a question I would like to address to
both the chancellor and the Prime
Minister today an agreement was signed
for freedom of movement or and also
one for a professional qualifications
the doctors however see their future in
Germany prime minister Rana you quite
often spoke about
you quite often demanded from the
countries of the European Union that
they give back
on these Investments these are after all
Investments that were taken into the
future qualifications of people with uh
from the Albanian taxpayer so we would
like to get something back is there a
possibility a mechanism for how to do
this and the spokesperson of the British
government today reacted to your
declaration yesterday how do you see
this
one of the main
Dutch English free the free movement of
Labor is is one of the main advantages
of the European Union so all that are
going to join the union are willing to
accept this concept of free movement of
Labor which we have now for more than
400 million people and if we look to the
workforce 220 million and if you look at
it it works more or less quite well
not because of the movement to some
countries but if you go to the details
you see that it is very easy for young
people and for all the others just to
take the decision to to do it for some
years in another country and doing this
and going back is something that is
enlarging the experiences and the
advantages of many many people and so
I'm very sure that free movement of
Labor is a very good concept for all of
us yes you are right saying that brain
drain is a problem for countries looking
at the different uh wages you have in in
the member states of the European Union
and this is even so for all those
countries that are already member but if
you look to it you see many of them
going back
later in their lives and then
the country is profiting from the
experiences that they
reached abroad and if you look for
instance to Germany you will find many
Germans all over Europe doing their jobs
going there for five years for 10 years
for 15 years sometimes going back
sometimes not so this is this is
something which is in a way already
something that works for all
the other question is what can we do
that people like to stay in their
country and this is the only answer of
this is Hope if we are making it very
good and developing the countries
creating a better economic atmosphere
making feasible that good jobs and good
future is feasible in all the member
states of the opinion and those
countries that are willing to join
the union I think this is the best
answer to this problem
we if you look over time for free
movement of Labor and the chancellor has
already said how beneficial it is for
all sides that you see we have had this
process of put partial brain drain in
any country that was in the accession
process
and the closer you come to accession the
less
strong this effect is the solution is in
raising the living standards that's our
common goal but there are also below
that one because this takes time and
this is of course for uh families for
example in the western Balkans who want
to keep their young people close to them
a difficult question if you see the time
Dimension there are quite good examples
where you have agreements cross-border
for example for medical doctors to have
an exchange for a few years and then to
come back and to deliver on the
experience that is gained and there are
many very good examples for that so this
is something we can can learn on and as
you prime minister raised the question
of universities and cooperation and of
course in universities are for example
also medical faculties this might be a
topic that we should develop in depth
also for example Erasmus so the movement
of students
within the Western Balkans and the
European Union we have started to work
on that but it could be a very
interesting point and Delivery for the
Western Balkan Summit to come with
Solutions and to come with proposals on
this for you so important question
thank you I'm not aware what
the spokesman of the British government
said today but
I think that
this country here
is a
great example that Britain and the
British government should look into
Germany
had the same problem similar
some years ago when with the big wave of
the refugee crisis
also people from our region and also
people from Albania joined
and I never heard
any German politician let alone
government minister
talk about invasion
and I never heard any German politician
let alone
government minister or interior Minister
talk about
uh albanians
being
criminals and bringing criminals but I
saw
a government that was very interested to
address the issue
with dignity and respect for the
Albanian people and to move forward
concretely by first
putting Albania in the countries of safe
origin
tightening up the system of applications
and practically ending that moment of
somehow
[Music]
turbulence
in the most dignified and in the most
respectful way
so instead of fueling
crazy Narrative of Invaders and
gangsters
to cover up for totally failed policies
on borders
and on crime the British Representatives
need to come to Germany and learn
quick and fix their their own problems
we are not here I mean here in Albania
to fix the problems they have in uh
in Britain and secondly I have to to
remind that
our people until they reach France they
are totally legal
so if there is a problem in the channel
between France and Britain
they have to work with each other and to
find a way to solve it I know brexit has
made it more difficult but this was a
decision of the British people not of
the Albanian or of the French people and
at the end we are very much
happy to cooperate
to do whatever we can on our side
but we'll never ever accept this kind of
rhetoric albanians in Britain are a
great Community fully integrated
70 percent of them and they are not
millions they are just 140
000
and for 140 000 people of another
Community Germany would never would not
even count just to be to be concrete
that 70 of them left Greece and left
Italy and didn't leave Albania so uh uh
they are there are 1 200 Business
Leaders albanians there are very uh
well-respected academics and so on and
so further and when it comes to
criminals in the British jails the
number is uh less than one percent so to
single out the community and to talk
about gangsters and about criminals
doesn't sound really something that is
very British sounds more like screams
from a madhouse
a question addressed to Federal
Chancellor Schultz you said the
conflicts in the Balkan regions are
supposed to be settled and they need to
be settled also if we look at this
Crossroads this watershed moment that we
experience right now in Germany and
France tabled a proposal to solve the
Kosovo question the sort of the
normalization between Serbian Kosovo so
my question is how urgent is an
agreement and your view between Kosovo
and Serbia and when do you expect this
to happen and if we still have time for
a short question address to the three of
you
yesterday during the Civil Society Forum
a wish was voiced to also have a
timetable for enlargement how realistic
how desirable is this
thank you very much
the question
thank you very much for the question
and it's true the bilateral conflicts
that undoubtedly exist between certain
member states of the western Balkans
need to be settled they need to be
overcome so it's a good thing to do be
able to do this this year we've already
made enormous progress for example as
regards to debate between Bulgaria and
North Macedonia and present
um
already spoke about a success of this
meeting
um
processes that have taken place was
Albania and North Macedonia looking
ahead towards a possible a new accession
and for Serbia and Kosovo
this also applies an agreement must be
reached
we the French government and also the
European commission are trying our
utmost to make this possible
we're very actively involved in talks
with both parties and we hope that very
soon we will come to a process where
both governments
will move forward and and understanding
can be reached
there's something for which we need to
have patience and obviously we need to
put a lot of effort into it and we hope
that very soon we'll see a positive
outcome as regards enlargement I think
the best thing would be for the
commission president to address that I
would say as fast as possible
um the after all the decisions of death
Thessaloniki um date back 90 to 19 years
ago nobody at the time would have
expected it to take so long so we need
to speed up matters
first of all from the Europeans
commission side I want to emphasize that
there's full support for the
franco-german proposal
and we integrate that in the dialogue
that is so necessary so we call on both
sides to move forward on that because
this is a bridge that is being built to
solve a problem that can be solved but
that is
in the way of a speedier accession
process for the region what the
timetable is concerned the accession
process is completely merits based so
there is no widget timetable and that's
good
the better a country performs in its own
interest with investment and reforms the
faster the process goes but we also have
of course uh the other way around that
with non-implementation for example from
reforms or not
undergoing reforms we see a slowing down
of the process the modernized
methodology
has as a purpose to speed up the process
if there is the willingness to really
work hard for example on the general
questions of the rule of law and the
principal values of the European Union
so it gives the opportunity uh compared
to former times to really speed up the
process and at the moment being I must
say we we feel a Wind of Change going
through Europe because of the
geopolitical situation it is of utmost
importance to push forward the accession
process of the western Balkan and here
we share the same attitude we want our
friends to be in the European Union
foreign
I must say first of all that
the new
German and French Plan offered to Serbia
and kosova is a
really a great
opportunity not just for Serbian kosova
but
for the region for Europe
and uh
I very much hope that both sides will
take it very seriously
and both sides will understand that
it's time to to see it also as an
important contribution to the whole
European
architecture of security
on the other hand when it comes to
enlargement I'm the
the worst person to to be asked but in
general but in this case I want to say
that independently from how the
enlargement will go
we are now in a completely different
level of cooperation with the European
Union
and this today is one of the examples
there are other Regional initiatives
that are important there is also the
continuous
path of common Summits between the
European Union and the Western Balkans
there is a new political community so
the space
of dialogue of cooperation of
mutual understanding and mutual
efforts has increased has been enlarged
a lot
of course we need to do our own homework
to get in the European unions this will
not change and this should not change
because the work needed
to become a full member is first of all
a work that improves
our own
performance
and makes our states functioning
democracies at their best
so we don't need
discounts and we are not going to ask
for discounts and finally I want to to
say that
wedding process
has proven itself
so good and so efficient when it comes
to the political understanding
and when it comes to strengthening this
sense of belonging to the same space
being named European union or being
named just Europe
and now it's time to to push to make it
more consistent more concrete also to
try and give common answers to to
questions like brain drain to questions
like better wages to questions like
better quality of life and so on and so
further because
Germany and the the big rich countries
of Europe will continue to be attractive
for our people as they are for many
people and we can't change that by
telling them to uh to regress we have to
run into progress as much as we can with
their help and uh the great the
sensation I have is that there is really
a strong strong will to help so we can't
ask for more thank you very much
Chancellor thank you Ursula and uh let
me finish by saying when we had the the
signatures
we were four albanians two Germans
and some others now there are two
Germans one albanians so it's it's you
know albanians should really understand
that we have never ever been better than
today of course there is better in the
future
so
foreign
[Music]